eu sempre quis ser um revolucionário
desde pequeno e até hoje eu tenho um
grande medo eu tenho certeza que é o
medo de cada um de vocês é viver os anos
que nós temos ainda diante e morrer
passando por esse mundo nulo vazio sem
sentido sem ter feito algo de grande com
a minha própria vida
esse é o meu medo desde pequeno e até
hoje e por causa disso desde cedo eu
procurei algo grande pelo qual de cá
minha vida eu procurei esses grandes
revolucionários e essas grandes
revoluções que podiam servir para mim
como motivação para que eu pudesse
também a minha vida por esses projetos
lá quando eu comecei a estudar história
principalmente a partir da oitava série
antiga 8ª série
aqueles homens e aquelas mulheres que
atravessaram a história da humanidade
dando a vida delas por aquilo em que
elas acreditavam mexia tanto comigo que
eu queria encontrar a minha revolução eu
sempre quis encontrar uma revolução e da
minha vida por essa revolução
a questão é que quanto mais eu
encontrava estes homens e estas mulheres
mas eu percebi que muitos deles estavam
dispostos a matar por aquilo em que eles
acreditavam que não queria matar por
aquilo que eu acreditava eu estava
disposto até a morrer por aquilo em que
eu acreditava mas nunca morrerá matar e
por causa disso essas revoluções nunca
de fato entraram dentro de mim porque
elas não correspondiam plenamente aquilo
que eu desejava e nessa busca incansável
um dia eu encontrei um padre que me
disse olha gabriel esse seu desejo de
revolução ele é bom
é justo é uma motivação boa e eu
inclusive tem esse desejo
eu vou mostrar a você um revolucionário
que com a própria vida dividiu a
história da humanidade em antes e depois
dele e ele mostrou um homem que até
então eu não conhecia esse jesus que
muitos de nós quando escutamos o nome
torcemos o nariz ou temos uma série de
preconceitos por causa de inúmeras
religiões
foi jesus que eu não encontro não tinha
descoberto porque meu jesus de antes
eram jesús dátolo bobo e infantil
o jesus que se padre me mostrava eram
jesus decidido autêntico disposto a dar
a vida era um homem que não conhecia
aos poucos então eu fui encontrando esse
jesus e fui percebendo
eu tinha duas opções diante desse homem
ou eu passava a minha vida teorizando
sobre ele
estudando sobre ele refletindo sobre ele
isso seria bom eu diria até algumas
frases de motivação algumas frases de
efeito para a minha vida mas eu tenho
uma segunda opção
a segunda opção era mais desafiadora era
procurar viver como esse homem de dois
mil anos atrás
bush era procurar viver como esse homem
muitas vezes apagado pela história hoje
era procurar viver como esse homem de
dois mil anos atrás e que muitas vezes
nós olhamos torcemos nariz
hoje diante dessas duas opções
eu fiquei com a segunda o que fazer
então eu tenho dentro de mim um grande
sonho ser hoje esse homem de dois mil
anos atrás como fazer isso então eu me
propôs alguns exercícios o primeiro
exercício era olhar para dentro
ela tem a coragem de travar os duelos
dentro de mim mesmo porque é verdade
fazer revolução fora é um grande desafio
mas a revolução mais exigente a
revolução que mais custa e por causa
disso a revolução mais autêntica é
aquela que começa dentro de nós
se você consegue travar as suas próprias
batalhas você vence qualquer batalha
pois as isso então era nas linhas
meditações diárias silêncio olhar para
mim olhar para esse homem e ver as
diferenças entre ele e aí vocês devem
imaginar as inúmeras diferenças entre eu
e ele
ainda hoje porque o exercício é diário o
exercício de fazer revolução dentro de
mim
o exercício de ter a coragem de olhar
para dentro o que infelizmente a nossa
geração não consegue por causa desse
nome
barulho incapaz de parar
depois desse ponto quando eu olhei para
mim mesmo estava na hora de desfazer o
segundo ponto é o segundo ponto era os
homens que seguiam aquele 2 mil anos
atrás diria é preciso viver com
essencial outro grande problema
vocês hão de convir comigo porque nós
somos uma geração do supérfluo e numa
geração do essencial abrir então guarda
roupa e o que eram 45 pares de sapatos
se tornar um dois pares de sapato
o que era 15 10 calças se tornaram 34
calças o que eram inúmeras camisas se
tornaram 10 12 camisas viver com o
essencial viver com o essencial e tudo
aquilo que é supérfluo das pessoas que
mais precisam
só que nessa época eu era jornalista
repórter de uma rádio aqui do recife e
eu estava ficando numa situação
complicada
estava ficando como cebolinha uma calça
só uma camisa só até que eu disse a ele
olha essa né
daqui a pouco eu dou trabalho nesse dia
justamente nesse dia chegando na rádio
operador de som ele disse gabriel
hoje eu ganhei uma camisa e eu queria te
dar a essa é a lógica de quem procura
viver dessa forma quem dá tudo ganha
tudo
essa é a lógica de quem empreende a
própria vida nesse sonho quem dá todo
ganha tudo mas é preciso arriscar tudo
a nossa geração está disposta e quer
deseja isso grandes ideais e grandes
sonhos mas não está disposta a arriscar
a própria vida
quem arrisca nada ganha nada
quem arrisca 50% ganha 50% quem arrisca
tudo ganha tudo é preciso dar tudo tudo
as grandes revoluções as revoluções mais
consistentes na história da humanidade
não foram feitas por homens e mulheres
que dedicaram o tempo livre
as revoluções que se perpetuaram na
história foram feitas por homens e
mulheres que dedicaram a vida toda toda
quantos de nós agora estamos dispostos a
dar tudo por aquilo que nós queremos
realizar
quem dá tudo ganha tudo novo experiência
estava passando um dia na minha rua e
seu israel que é um rapaz que sempre
fica pedindo dinheiro no sinal desse
gabriel tem uma coisa para me dar
eu tinha alguma coisa pra dar
só que eu tenho duas notas de vinte
reais a gente dá 20 centavos a moedinha
é o que sobra mais duas notas de vinte
reais
é claro que eu disse não tenho não só
que o sinal fechou nessa hora o rapaz
que estava dentro do carro para o carro
abriu o vidro e disse olhe se pensar
muito não dá nada
eita que ainda tudo ganha tudo abrir a
carteira e os 40 reais a ser rafael e
foi embora
neste final de semana fui visitar minha
família que mora no interior do estado e
lá no domingo quando estava voltando
para recife
minha mãe disse gabriel eu tenho 50
reais na carteira e eu queria te dar
quem dá tudo ganha tudo quem dá tudo
ganha tudo que ainda tudo ganha tudo
quando então eu estava no essencial que
estava pronto para o terceiro passo o
passo de ir ao encontro das pessoas que
mais precisam dessa experiência
muitas pessoas pensam que a
espiritualidade ea religião são ópio do
povo
as pessoas que têm uma experiência
religiosa como ópio do povo são pessoas
que não entraram aprofundamento da
experiência religiosa espiritual a
religião nunca é o ópio do povo quando
ela é vivida de maneira autêntica
integral profunda adulta
por isso eu preciso fazer essa
experiência ea experiência era uma hora
duas horas da manhã e pelas ruas do
recife encontrar as pessoas que mais
precisavam da minha ajuda e eu então me
vestir de uma forma mais simples
principalmente pensando nos catadores de
lixo e de madrugada pra rua andar com
eles conversar com eles ajudá los a
catar lixo enfim fazer esse trabalho e
descobrir um mundo que eu não conhecia
antes porque antes sim
a minha experiência era de um jesus
vizinho
eu vivia na minha bolha de
espiritualidade
depois que encontrei essa nova forma
esse novo sonho pelo qual queria a minha
vida eu descobri uma realidade que eu
não encontrava antes
e sejamos honestos quantos de nós
conhecemos a realidade da nossa cidade
quantos de nós experimentamos a
realidade da nossa cidade
a primeira experiência então com os
catadores de lixo foi me sentir
rechaçado rejeitado excluído
muitos deles pensavam que eu estava lá a
competir pelo lixo deles e eles me
tratavam como eu tratava a eles quando
estava dentro do meu carro
então eu senti na pele aquilo que eu e
me perdoem
muitos de nós fazemos diariamente
inclusive quando nós saímos daqui hoje
enquanto nós falamos de revolução
nós não fazemos a nossa pequena
revolução
eu lembro que numa madrugada andando com
um deles catando lixo um deles
ele colocou a no lixo de um forte grito
por sua mão de uma ratazana grudada na
mão dele causando enorme e quando ele
jogou a mão
a ratazana uma grande parte realmente da
mão dele tenha sido comida e aquele
homem gritava tanto de dor e eu me
perguntava até que ponto a minha
experiência espiritual é capaz de dar
uma resposta a isso
aos poucos então aquela minha
experiência começava em quetta alguns
amigos meus que me conheciam de antes
dessa experiência eles me perguntavam
existiam perguntando o que é isso que é
isso que é isso que está acontecendo com
você porque você tá diferente
no primeiro momento não dava muita
atenção até que eu percebi que estava
diferente era um sonho que eu estava
vivendo e partilhei com 11 começava a
viver depois dois depois 3 10 50 100 150
ea coisa ficou maior e surgiu a
comunidade dos viventes a comunidade dos
viventes
é uma comunidade que reúne homens e
mulheres dispostos a dar a própria vida
por esse sonho
a comunidade dos viventes
homens e mulheres dispostos a dedicar à
própria vida pra ser aquele de dois mil
anos atrás hoje aqui agora
essa é a comunidade dos viventes
espalhada em inúmeras cidades e depois
fazendo inúmeros trabalhos como o
projeto vincular o projeto vincular esse
trabalho social da comunidade que reúne
hoje uma rede de voluntários que passa
de mil pessoas que fazem de forma mais
organizada aquilo que antes e ainda hoje
porque ainda hoje eu faço isso eu fazia
andar nas ruas
a comunidade dos eventos que é uma única
coisa a mata e às últimas consequências
como jesus porque se existe uma coisa
que jesus pediu quando ele esteve aqui
não foi nada mais nada menos do que nós
devemos nos amar como ele nos amou e ele
nos amou até às últimas consequências
até o fim até o extremo disposto a dar
vida não amor sentimento um amor bobinho
água com açúcar
como já é comum a gente ver na internet
mas o amor decisão um amor que aposta a
vida que está disposto a perder a vida
pelo outro
duas características desse amor o
primeiro é um amor universal aberto a
todos e por causa disso a comunidade
apesar de ser católica ela é aberta a
outras convicções religiosas ao diálogo
com outras convicções religiosas
inclusive com pessoas sem uma convicção
religiosa porque se é verdade que eu sou
crente ele não é mais verdade ainda que
as minhas inquietações e as deles são
comuns
nós podemos nos unir o amor universal e
depois o amor que vai até às últimas
consequências devido no dia a dia porque
se você espera para a mata e às últimas
consequências como jesus foi crucificado
você só pode ir fazer isso se você tiver
na síria mas aqui agora nós podemos
vivenciar isso por exemplo ou mais
assiste agora eu preciso falar para cada
um de vocês mandam até às últimas
consequências
eu preciso olhar para cada um de vocês
dando tudo de mim para que vocês se
sintam as pessoas mais importantes do
mundo agora imagine
imaginem se isso deixa de ser somente
uma vivência minha e passa a ser nossa
imaginem se além se no lugar de nós nos
odiarmos uns aos outros nos amarmos uns
aos outros e não o quer
amor o amor disposto a dedicar a vida a
perder a vida pelo outro
o outro é o mais importante nos últimos
seis anos
eu concluo com isso eu tenho perdido
muitas pessoas importantes na minha vida
nos últimos seis anos eu perdi sete
pessoas importantes na minha vida
primos tios e amigos alguns em
circunstâncias digamos naturais como
meus avós que morreram no alto dos seus
80 e tantos anos mas também um primo que
morreu na adolescência numa situação tão
difícil
um amigo que morreu com 18 anos de
meningite
uma prima que morreu agora há pouco de
câncer
todas as vezes que eu ia visitá los no
hospital ou e no enterro eu olhava para
ele se perguntava se fosse eu agora se
fôssemos nós agora coloquem se diante da
morte de vocês esse agora nesse instante
nesse momento tudo acabasse se agora
nesse instante
nesse momento eu morresse eu teria feito
a minha vida vale a pena eu teria
descoberto o sonho da minha vida eu
teria dedicado à minha vida por algo
grande
eu espero sinceramente que cada um de
nós descubra o próprio sonho porque é
muito triste morrer e perfeito da
própria vida um mero nascer crescer e se
reproduzir morrer como os animais
nós somos feitos para coisas muito
grandes
a coisa maior que eu encontrei na minha
vida foi reproduzir
hoje esse homem de dois mil anos atrás o
meu sonho é ser como esse homem hoje o
meu sonho é dedicar à minha vida hoje
para ser aquele de dois mil anos
eu espero que cada um de vocês de
verdade descubram próprio sonho mas não
somente porque isso é pouco
eu espero que vocês estejam dispostos a
dedicar vida por esse sonho de vocês
porque se você se dedicar à minha vida
eu prometo eu garanto acreditem não
somente a vida de vocês
isso passa a ter mais sentido não
somente a vida de cada um de vocês
começa a ser grande plena cheia
realizadora
mas a revolução silenciosa que comessem
cada um de nós começa aos poucos a
questionar a incomodar os que estão
perto esses que estão perto fazendo o
sonho do outro o próprio sonho e quando
nós sonhamos juntos nós construímos
grandes coisas
quando nós construímos juntos os sonhos
de todos e não somente o meu
o mundo pode ser diferente e aquilo que
muitos de nós pensamos que é uma utopia
pode se tornar realizável
e aquele som e de uma nova humanidade
que muitos dos pais dos avós que estão
aqui virão nos livros de história pode
ser realizado por nós aqui agora
começando por nós
basta descobrir o próprio sonho e que
seja um sonho grande porque pequenos
projectos a nossa vida já está cheia e
que nos projetos não realizam o homem
sonhos grandes é que realiza um homem
sonhos grandes é que proporcionam
mudanças verdadeiras na sociedade sonhos
grandes é o que nos fazem homens e
mulheres de verdade
dispostos a dar a vida uns pelos outros
construindo uma utopia não uma realidade
de nova humanidade eu espero que juntos
a partir de hoje nós nos llanos crentes
ou não com convicção religiosa ou não
mas juntos nós possamos começar aqui e
agora essa revolução que nós queremos
construir e ver realizada eu conto com
vocês espero que vocês contem comigo
porque eu quero da minha vida por isso
obrigado